okay cool so um
again i'm sean kenny and i'm going to be
talking about testing android at spotify
and just some of the
higher level principles and
methodologies that we're using to
test our app and then also diving into a
couple key places just to show
some of the
underlying features and
sort of implementations that we have
for testing
so um
pretty much we move really fast here so
it's definitely agile
i'm not really sure exactly what kind of
agile it is but it's agile and we start
a release cycle
by you know designing and then building
and then testing and then releasing it's
just one big cycle
that repeats
and the end of this cycle we get a
released
version of the app that actually goes to
the app store and all of you can enjoy
either way
you look at this like anyway look at
this it's just a tight cycle and we move
fast and we release every three weeks
and if there's a bug um
we're going to ship your bug and once
your bug is shipped um it's going to be
a little while till that bug goes away
because people install it and then
eventually they'll need to get a new
version and things like that so
fast development cycle puts a little bit
more pressure on needing a good testing
system
we also have a lot of developers at
spotify so over the years
brian was saying he was the first
new york city android engineer i don't
know exactly where that is here but um
right now it's it's a lot of people so
we have um over 40 contributors um
committing code to the code base and
that's like regular committers we also
have people that you know just
maybe fix a bug or they they didn't have
anything to do that weekend and fix the
book for us which is great
um
so
pretty much
there's a lot of people there's you
don't know what everybody's committing
anymore you could break someone's stuff
they could break your stuff so testing
is becoming really really important
especially with a lot of people using
the app
however i can prove to you that
even though we have more people we're
releasing quickly
and we're growing and the app is getting
more complex
the crashiness of the app is actually
going down so if you look at 1.1.0
um compared to 1.6.0 um that is actually
crashing um about 20 less um than than
the actual well it's sorry it's five
times less than 1.1.0
so that's pretty awesome
when we put this together it was it was
really
eye-opening
to see that and just by adhering to some
tense testing principles making sure
you're doing what's right in terms of
testing
you can definitely like do this and get
better over time instead of going in the
opposite direction
so
how do we do that we protected our code
with tests um really mean nasty tests
that are great and defend babies
um so we write unit tests
automation tests um we do exploratory
testing we have all kinds of different
testing
and um the way this kind of shakes out
this is kind of how i look at it i mean
you could probably break this up
different ways
we have unit tests at the bottom of our
pyramid that are pretty much you know
they're they're all robo-electric tests
and you don't necessarily need to use
roboelectric for this but
we really like it and i'll go through a
couple reasons why
we also are doing automated tests
and that kind of includes ui tests like
actually clicking around doing specific
use cases
smoke testing uh stress testing too
integration testing end-to-end tests and
then at the top we're still doing what
we like to call exploratory testing
where we have
many people using the app and just sort
of exploring figuring out what's wrong
with it
so um first step to
achieving less crashiness
you take
a strong stance on making unit tests so
unit tests are literally our first line
of defense against bugs
so
um
we pretty much like took the stance of
you write unit tests if you're not
writing unit tests then you pretty much
just wrote legacy code at this point
because it needs to be tested
why would you write unit tests
you ensure that all your code pets are
you know working as you thought they
would
you root out complex things in your
application
i've refactored many classes because it
wasn't testable and at the end i don't
think i've ever done that and thought
like i had like a worse thing there
it's just more modular you know you
could
use dependency injection or something
like that it was it was really nice and
testing kind of forces you down that
path
um
what do we test typical paths the happy
path if you will
we test like weird data conditions empty
sets
maybe like
you know
off by one errors or like
lengths on sub substrings the extremas
or something like that there's there's a
lot of things to test but unit tests can
normally cover a lot of different things
so what we use is roboelectric
and um it's basically a really really
fast way of doing unit tests for android
so it uses the jvm if you don't know
what robe electric is
to run your tests you don't have to like
start android or anything like that
and it provides you with
basically shadows of the
the classes and objects that you're used
to using in in an android environment
and does things like
inflating layouts
loading resources
pretty much anything that you need to do
but you don't have to start android
anymore to do that it's really good
we don't even use a custom test runner
we just use out of the box it's it's
good
and we actually i believe have committed
code to make it even better
we use maquito a lot
like what would what would unit testing
be without a good mocking framework it's
really really fluent
it lets us test things like network
connections
maybe other services or libraries that
we're not interested in testing so
really helps you focus
on testing the thing that you built
and then you can start to
just mock everything else at that point
another tool that i actually learned
about here
that i really like is assertj
and this really makes testing
android components really easy
especially views you can see if they're
gone or they're invisible
it's very fluent so you don't have to
like string a bunch of assert conditions
on multiple lines you can just sort of
string together a bunch of commands that
you think the view state should be in
and i actually don't think
um
we're actually using fest and it's been
rebooted as a cert j android i believe
at this point i'm not sure how recent
that that was
so um just gonna pull up some code here
and show you an example of how we test
our fragments and fragments are kind of
like i look at them um as one of the
harder things to test and just sort of
review some of the pieces
of doing that
so
okay
so this is actually um
one of our fragment tests and this is
testing um a list of
basically listeners for a piece of
music that others have
sort of navigated to
so one thing that makes testing
fragments easier for us
is we actually have a very nice
base class that we call our roboelectric
fragment test case and pretty much what
you do is you just pass this
the fragment class it's generic so you
can pass in other fragment classes as
well and then you just have to implement
a single method that
pretty much does all the work
setting up that specific fragment here
for you in terms of setting up an
activity that uses a special activity
that we use just for testing
starting it with the proper life cycle
a thing for us so we can't use like
standard robo-electric start activity is
like setting up a new theme
for us so this class is basically an
extension of the base class that just
implements a single method and at the
end of it if you do this properly
in all your tests you can just
easily have a base condition
or a base method here called start
fragment and then it gives you the
fragment and it set up an activity and
you really don't have to worry about
anything um what we were finding before
um especially with activity testing is
that like each class was doing a lot of
the same things starting um a shared
activity setting the theme doing a like
setting a custom
preference saver and things like that so
we sort of consolidated all this logic
for um testing fragments into a base
class so that's that's kind of like one
quick win you can do
if you're using roboelectric and then
roboelectric as you can see like again
think about this in the jvm just
executing so
now you have a fragment now you can get
the view you can get the list view you
can do some quick assertions on that
view
using a cert j or fest so you can see
that it's not or that it's gone so for
this specific
fragment test
it's actually pretty simple which is why
i chose it so we test a couple key
states we test that it's empty if no
data was around we test the network
error state so if the
if there was a network problem getting
the request we set up some mocks to do
that and then we make sure that the
proper view is shown
we also test things you know just the
happy pets so right now we set up some
mock data when this is a helper method
that basically says you're online and
you're going to return valid data for
this list and then we're querying the
list view to make sure that the mock
data has been loaded properly and it has
the proper counts
it's just a nice quick way to verify
that your fragment is working the way
that you expect it to
and it's really really fast to run and
it it really makes you happier as a
developer to be able to quickly put
these together and run them and just
know that things aren't broken without
having to go through all this
so if we jump over to
roboelectric
fragment test case as well
so this is the things that i'm talking
about that make this a little bit
that sort of takes the onus off you as
the developer so um
we're using
content providers here so we're
registering a custom content provider
we're
putting some mocks into the activity to
be used we're injecting a fragment
generator this is all boilerplate stuff
that was kind of
used or the same general pattern was
being used we also tear things down
properly clear test injections
and then this is the piece that
starts an actual activity that you can
work with so we use the standard build
activity
we actually get that activity and then
we do other things with it that our
application needs your application might
not need it but
it's possible that you do
okay
so i'm just going to jump back
so that's just like a glimpse into
roboelectric testing um it's really
really useful and powerful and you this
this is an example of the fragment any
time you need to use a context like i
have tests that are just testing logging
classes that need a context so they can
make like an http request or something
like that um
or a loader um so
you can use roboelectric for those kinds
of tests really really easily
so i highly recommend it
so we're actually at today 38 coverage
of our app i know that's not awesome or
anything like that but it used to be
like five percent and we're going up
um so we're we're getting better we're
improving um
we're going to get to
100 someday
and then all these robo-electric test
cases because they run so fast and
they're so um you know easy to run not
only are developers earning them but on
every commit that you make
um to a code review system that we use
called garrett
it's running these tests for you and
it's telling you if you broke anybody
else's stuff so you can actually like
multitask at this point you can make
some changes and ship it off to team
city and then have it run some tests and
tell you if anything broke
well you're maybe doing something else
or went to lunch so it's nice
we run these tests the most out of any
other testing layer
there's lots and lots of tests and they
run often all the time
and then we're also actually like
showing people the testing
levels of things they're working on so
we break our app into spotlits
so this is actually a feature in the
spotify app i don't know if you can read
it but if you use radio
radio is awesome ninety percent
uh test coverage so if that crashes i
would be pretty surprised
um but i don't know about these guys
here
okay so that's that's unit testing so we
also do a whole different level of this
which is test automation
um
and so test automation let's
let's just show you guys test automation
real quick
it's pretty exciting actually
so what this is going to do is just run
a pretty simple test that starts the app
and verifies
a play count for a shared item
so i'm going to run this
and it should kick off
and then i also need an emulator as well
and i'm using genymotion
so we're building x86
come on
let's look at the console
oh here we go
so okay so basically this test runner a
couple of things it does it
installs the app uninstalls the app um
well okay so first it uninstalls the app
reinstalls it make sure that you're sort
of at a base condition with the latest
version of your apk
and then
it acquires a new user and we have a
centralized way of doing that with a
service um and it when you're acquiring
user you tell it the kind of user that
you want premium something like that
and then it goes through a test process
and for some reason mine is snowing
which is interesting
um and it's sharing a post right now
and then it's going to go to the
activity feed pull the refresh just to
see that that thing that you shared came
up
play it
and then verify that the replay count
was incremented
um
cool so that's just one example of a ta
test and that's actually like a really
simple ta test they get pretty pretty
intricate and i'll i'll show you an
example of that
and this is just sort of the output of
that command so a little glimpse into
what's happening is right here you guys
can probably see the 200 but we're
starting a server connection and we're
starting to send commands that map to
um
basic um test automation drivers that
are baked into the debug version of the
app none of this stuff is actually put
into um a release version um but the
debug version is a little bit super and
has as extra stuff to automate some of
this testing
so this is
an older example of like what we're
actually doing so we have devices that
are plugged into a computer
and we're picking the most popular
devices at this point
so for example
sorry i lost my note
we have like samsung's or nexuses and
things like that and then we also have
x86 emulators as well um running these
tests um and we're currently in the
process of upgrading this a little bit
to use um
a more advanced system with like a usb
hub and things like that so
we're
continuing to improve this but testing
on real devices is a good thing
so this is actually an example of the
test of a test that's run and the test
you just saw
used a system like this this is a graph
model for testing
and
it's actually really really powerful you
may have used depending on what you've
worked with like
dsl versions of testing like gherkin or
something like that
um
so this is another way of doing that you
represent um what you're doing and the
edges here so you're performing an
action and then in the vertexes you have
different states that you're going to
check
and
the power behind this which
which is really really cool is
when you have this test set up you can
walk it with another tool called graph
walker in a variety of different ways so
you can walk it randomly until you hit
every edge
you can walk it a star until you
maybe reach five minutes or something
like that so
using this way of defining tests
you can actually um
create
a system that is
a little bit more complicated and
performs
a different array of being able to test
a single thing so you can walk this in
many different ways and
you've just made a pretty complicated
use case using just a gui tool and then
a command line tool to convert that to
actual code and this gets converted to
java code just like your dsls or
something like that you'd run a command
you'd get an interface that you
implement
and then that gets run as part of your
test model
so and this is an example of the code
that you spit out when you're building
these models so
here is an edge that needs to click
user's profile
here's an edge that needs to go back
and when you're implementing this as a
developer you actually make it do these
things it's it's really you know
it's dumb it's not going to do that for
you
and then this is a a pretty interesting
uh sequence diagram of of what's
happening when we're actually running
these
automated tests
and just to sort of like walk you
through this i know it's it's big but if
you break it up it's not too bad and it
might make things a little bit more
clear
so
on the console you actually saw you were
issuing commands
page.navigate or something like that
that command gets transmitted over a
socket
to a socket server that we call bean
remote
and then it gets dropped into an
interpreted environment that you may or
may not have heard of called bean shell
and
it's more or less our scripting
environment you could probably do this
in javascript or something like that if
you're inventive but we're just using
bean shell
which is a small lightweight
tool to execute java
as a scripting language very small
that actually calls
something
that's
implemented
the graph calls that you just converted
and you implemented that interface so
you have a page implementation that
clicks a button or
goes backwards or goes back
and then that page implementation is
actually communicating with an
automation driver that's baked into the
fragment that actually sends those
commands or ui inputs or whatever you
need to do
to
fulfill the action that you wanted to do
once the operation is complete it
collects things like in the example i
showed it would click the button and
then collect the current play count
returns the result
and if it needs to there is a step to
convert data like cursor data to
a more i guess an easier to use format
like just a standard object that can
then pass over the wire
um it returns that result to the bean
remote as it be it's just a socket
connection and then it goes back
as either like a simple string an
integer long or some serialized json
data that gets picked up and examined
and then the test model can
assert if that was actually
something that was expected or
unexpected
um so it's it's actually
once you get your header on it's it's a
pretty simple way of doing it it's
really really flexible
it's
similar to robotium in that we have like
a solo object that lets you do things
and command things and we're i guess a
couple two
key breakaways here is
we are breaking the logic into pages so
one major thing that we're using is the
concept of a page that really
consolidates all the logic for a
specific
um
it's either an activity or a fragment
normally so
each page will have a bunch of
functionality and then the bean remote
lets you control various pages or it has
like more useful things like controlling
navigation and things like that
so that's pretty much it there
so what this makes possible too is not
only these um
you know these predefined models that
people have to build and um you know
verify and that it fulfills testing
needs and conditions you can also just
do some really simple and convenient
smoke testing as well so we have a
couple systems smoke
stress testing systems that we've
implemented that are that have actually
found a couple
nice bugs at least for me like i've
already found two or three bugs because
of these particular tools
so the first one we call intent roulette
and intent roulette is basically a
system that takes every available intent
um randomizes it and then goes through
all those intents so
and then if anything crashes then you
know that you've broken something
it sounds like a really simple test but
i think sometimes you need simple tests
like that
because this really is a sanity smoke
test like if something is broken in this
intent roulette system
then
you know there's definitely something
you need to look at because it's not
doing anything really complicated
besides starting your activity or your
fragment
it's just
making an intent and using the shell am
command to start that intent
and verifying
that it didn't crash
we also have a really awesome tool
called monkey on steroids so if you've
ever
used the adb shell
monkey command this is a version of that
that you can control a little bit better
so we've given the monkey some steroids
in that it can now log into our app
and then it can navigate to a random
location
and then it can start to actually monkey
around and do random things
so it's it's just um
it's it's a monkey that takes a little
bit of you know pre
preconditions and things like that to
get you to somewhere where you want to
monkey around
and this monkey test is actually
implemented as a testing model um in our
in our system so we have our start
condition and then we install and we
make sure that we're still alive and
then we release the monkey here we
monkey around for a little while i think
it's
between like one thousand or two
thousand commands at random
and then after we're done we browse
again to a random location and if we're
still alive
um then we keep doing that and we do
this i think it's configurable but i
believe the default is like 30 minutes
and then run again or something like
that um so it's a really um nice way to
just sort of get out of your standard
testing methodology or models that
you've made and just see what happens in
pure chaos and try to uncover things and
you can also find things like memory
leaks because
you know this thing is just going on and
on and you you might have some memory
issues that you didn't you know
recognize that you had or something like
that
so um it's a pretty simple but powerful
um testing model and i i can actually
just sort of demo this real quick and
just show you guys like what that
process looks like
so unleashing the monkey
okay so
here's where we help the monkey a little
bit it's gonna
acquire a new user and and log them in
and then this is the point where we
literally when it says monkeying we just
use the shell command
um the shell
monkey script and
ooh it seems like it's gotten into the
debug settings that could be dangerous
oh god
oh man it crashed the app
monkeys
all right
so monkey made me look bad
we'll look at that later i promise
um okay so
we're running all these tests all the
time
they don't run on every commit but they
run like every hour
or hour and a half so once a test set
finishes it just picks up the latest
release version and then does its job
again
and
we can actually see what's happening all
the time on our ta automation test so
there's this on a monitor where i'm in a
room with our squad that's just sort of
showing us what's happening with the
specific features that we're working on
so
um i might walk in after a cup of coffee
and be like oh shoot this doesn't seem
like it's working anymore it looks like
i have something to do
um and then
um it's it's you're pretty much either
you know very very
happy with what's going on here you know
you have something to look into and we
do have like a very very nice tooling
around this as well so all the al our
test suite um our automated test suite
has a
centralized shared library that can
basically add new tests
every every test suite has access to
what's called a report object and it can
do things like upload screenshots so if
there's an issue you can actually click
on this go through and see the screens
for every step along the way and you
might see what happened but normally
what's more important is also like a
crash log or something like that
the test suite also has really really
awesome graphs that we're powering with
cabana
so
over here we have a graph of the
test failures per device here we have
just test passed and failed over the
last 12 hours here we have test
exceptions
based on
type of exception here we have test
failing per group so each group or each
suite can be broken up to different
groups with an annotation that we have
so it just uses that data to break it up
into groups here's actual crashes on the
latest version so we're just sort of
making this data um readily available
and up to date
so it makes the ta system even more
powerful because you can you know
constantly inspect the data that's
coming through
so the last thing that we do is
exploratory testing
this is dora the explorer
my daughter loves dora um
and so exploratory testing the best way
to do this at least i think is just to
be
organized
um at least up front so have like a
meeting and just sort of discuss like
what this app is doing like what are the
different
use cases
um what are the different conditions and
user conditions and things like that
trying to see
how complicated the app is and like how
many things need to be tested because a
lot of these are permutations of
of the previous thing you could choose
like one cell in each one of these um
columns um and then like make a test for
that or something
and then once you're organized and ready
um have like a lunch or get a bunch of
people together give them devices uh you
know not everybody has an android phone
maybe an iphone user could find a bug
that you didn't think about um just get
people together and and play with the
app test it try to break it
and have a little fun
but
exploratory testing is expensive and it
wastes people's time in some ways so
try to move your exploratory tests to
automated tests as much as possible so
that you know you don't have to keep
doing
each one of those processes in that
excel sheet that i showed you
you could automate that and you know
basically
make things a lot faster
and then we're also doing nightly builds
and this is kind of new we're using
a play store feature to allow people
within a domain spotify.com to get the
latest bleeding edge copy of
our android app
and download it and install it so this
is every night you get a new version of
the app installed i normally get it on
the train in the morning and
this gets 175 people
using your app daily um and it's it's
great like before it was a real problem
when you're working on a feature and
maybe the only people in your squad have
used it now you can you know release it
to the company and see if anybody finds
anything maybe they have feedback maybe
they you know
have an opinion about what you're doing
it just helps keep surprises down and
i think customers happy in the end
we're also doing crash reporting so we
use a system called hockey app to
basically get um all our crashes and
their api is really simple to use and
integrate with your application um i
don't know why this graph looks like
that that's interesting um we had a
really good day on the 27th apparently
um
but the takeaway here is you can see
your crash counts so if you're rolling
out you might notice that like you've
just introduced like a major crash group
or something like that
um you as a developer can go and search
and see
maybe some maybe you can find some
crashes that are happening in the wild
and get it get to get the stack trace
and sort of figure out the major issues
um i try to go here
every every couple days or something and
just see
you know
the features that i'm working on you can
give it a class path
are there any major issues so i think
the other day i fixed that one down
there that had 165 crashes on 1.8.0
and so this is really great and you know
it actually does make a difference so
just circling back
you know
this is a good trend here if we continue
this trend it's it's it's a good thing
um
crashing is you know not great for users
and we're doing less of it
with each version at this point and i
think it's because of the tests um that
we're doing and the automation tests and
the unit tests
and at this point like
i feel like we're starting to win a lot
um
we feel really good about what we're
doing and the processes that we have in
place to make sure we're not going in
the opposite direction in terms of
crashes and testing
and you know i think our users are
happier
we actually downloaded like google play
data and did some like sentiment
analysis people are cursing a lot less
when they're commenting about our app
which is a good thing
so just to recap
strive for higher coverages
make it easy to get started in testing
remember like the roboelectric
based test classes and the automation
tests we have so many helper libraries
for waiting and doing things and
reporting make it easy for developers to
test
run the tests as much as possible
unit test revolution tests you can run
so often every developer can do it
doesn't take much time at all to run the
entire suite ta tests take a little bit
longer but you can normally paralyze
that get more machines to do it
make your results available with
reporting the trs reporting that i
showed you with all the different colors
and and features you'll know when
something's broken
and then analyze what's happening and
then if it's not going the way you want
it re reanalyze and see what you need to
change to make you know stabler and
better
and that's it
questions
in production
yeah it's hockey
um i looked at the stack trace
oh you mean if it was like a device
independent thing that would be a little
bit harder to find that particular issue
is pretty clear but we do have um a lot
of like testing devices available so um
if if i suspect that that's the issue
i'll probably go borrow like five phones
from like a ta tester or something like
that on his desk and tell him i'll bring
them back tomorrow or something
sure so
did do you use hockey
like is that because that's what was
there and if it's not broke don't fix it
or evaluate the tools it seems like the
world has
yeah um unfortunately i'm not the best
person to answer that
um perhaps eric
might know a little bit more he's been
here longer
look at other wheels we look at other
options as well all the time we keep
evaluating every tool we have on a
regular basis
including
hockey app of course
yeah
it i mean
i know there's like crashlytics or
something like that
but i found that crash recording often
without a log doesn't give you a lot of
context
anything else over there
sure
so
that that test automation system is is
unique um
it's it's very custom for us and it's
probably a combination of just like
integrating with pre-existing things
that we have here like the test
reporting system is something that's
here for not only the android app but
the iphone app um things like that um
but
it's actually like pretty like simple
like it's not overly complicated to do
um if if you want to talk about like how
we actually do that um the high level is
that we're creating socket connections
and then we're using probably the key
thing is a thing called beam shell to
just execute commands that you're
sending over the wire and then we're
just doing some uh
basic parsing and deserialization
of the results and we're sending back
like
and 501s and things like that for air
conditions but um i mean you could
probably do it a different way but i
think the key takeaway is
just try to do automation to get like a
lot of the things done that you might be
doing yourself or other people are doing
try to try to get testing automated as
much as possible
and
try to make the data accessible that
you're you're getting from that
automated testing
i did not take it that far actually but
that would be interesting to see all i
did was do some analysis on basically
hockey app to get crashes for each
version um and
just sort of the way that that was
calculated is we we actually send um
a baseline crash like maybe every 1000
crashes that doesn't crash the app it's
just a non-crashing exception
that gets sent to hockey app and then we
know the general usage
and then we use that baseline to
pretty much calculate the actual
failing exception percentage
but i haven't tried to take that and
correlate that to anything else but
that'd be interesting to do for sure
so you're talking about the automation
drivers the things that are actually
clicking around and like doing the ui
interactions
cool so
the question is like how do we not
like i guess it's how do we not dirty
our app with that kind of thing
so
i think
the way it's been approached is so we
every fragment does implement an
interface that provides an automation
driver and then that class can really
live anywhere but normally it's baked as
a subclass in that fragment
however
these things these like different
fragments they don't they normally don't
do too much so it doesn't add too much
extra code and then the actual pieces
that communicate with that so there's
another layer here so you have that and
then you actually have the page object
that is talked to
remotely with these with the bean remote
and the the bean shell that is
considered i want to say an adapter to
those actual ui automations that the
fragment is doing
so that can be as complicated as you
need it to be and you actually wouldn't
be touching like actual like
ui code or actual um application code
that a regular
user would use on a daily basis
so it's it's it's layered a little bit
so there's there's there is a class in
between that talks to that automation
system and then it can sort of that
could compose a bunch of different
commands to do different things
that maybe the automation driver doesn't
do
um i believe that it's using just the
main activity so it's sending the it's
sending um a request to start the main
activity and it's sending along a little
bit extra
um
we use we use like uris to decide which
which place to go after that and the
main activity will typically take that
and start a subfragment or a fragment
from there
yep
oh
you
that's a great question how much time do
i actually spend testing versus
developing
um i think as the tooling gets better
i'm doing less testing so
um i think at the beginning
when i was still sort of getting used to
our setup and things like that i was
maybe like
60 40 or something like that but now
it's getting closer i want to say to
maybe like
i don't know 80 20 maybe a little bit
less
so um
i don't know like how you do testing but
i i haven't really gotten like test
driven first so i'll normally develop a
component and make it tested um but
i think the general takeaway here is i
i'm i'm trending downwards in the time
that i need to to write an actual test
for something i think that's because
there's a lot of people identifying the
pain points
so if like something is hard to test or
there's a core component that a lot of
people are using
somebody generally comes around and
provides
either a class or
a helper or something like that to
to make that process easier and we do
have like a java guild on where we can
talk about these things and make
the testing process
less painful
because if it's painful nobody's going
to do it
okay cool thank you everybody
thank you